Traductor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
¡Hola, qué tal!
¿Saben cómo me llaman?
Me llaman el psicólogo del dolor.
Feo, ¿no?
Bien, de hecho voy a hablar, un poquito.
El dolor es el problema
que ha traído de cabeza
a los profesionales de la salud
desde hace mucho tiempo.
Hay dos tipos de dolor:
el dolor agudo, que es el adaptativo,
y el doldor crónico, que no lo es tanto.
Hoy en día sabemos, que el dolor,
por investigaciones
que se han hecho y demás,
que el dolor se produce
100 % en el cerebro.
Por lo tanto, el dolor
depende de uno mismo.
Fíjaros, también se sabe
que el dolor es una emoción.
Y las emociones influyen mucho
en el manejo del dolor crónico,
se entremezclan, se potencian entre sí.
Les voy a contar
una metáfora que se llama
"La metáfora de bienvenidos
todos y el invitado grosero".
Para que entendamos un poco de
cómo van las emociones
con respecto al dolor.
Imaginemos que estáis, que vas a
organizar la fiesta de vuestra vida
en una ciudad y Uds.
son los anfitriones.
Solo hay una regla, que se debe
poner un cartel en la puerta:
"Bienvenidos todos".
Al estar el cartel en la puerta
"Bienvenidos todos",
todo el mundo puede entrar a la fiesta.
Empieza la fiesta y
empiezan a entrar invitados,
empiezan a disfrutar, a pasarla bien.
En eso, en un momento dado,
entra un invitado
grosero, mal oliente,
mal vestido, despeinado
y empieza a incordiar
a los demás invitados.
Claro, Uds. como buenos anfitriones,
agarráis a ese invitado
y lo sacáis a la calle.
Claro que en el momento
que lo sacáis a la calle,
como hay un cartel en la puerta
donde pone "Bienvenidos todos",
el invitado vuelve a entrar.
Y vuelve a incordiar
a los demás invitados.
Así una vez, otra vez,
hasta que pensáis, decidís,
bueno voy a agarrar al invitado,
lo voy a meter a una habitación;
pero al meterlo a la habitación,
tenéis que estar en la puerta
pendiente para que no salga,
para que no empiece a molestar
a los demás invitados.
Mi pregunta es,
¿estáis Uds. como anfitriones,
verdaderamente disfrutando de la fiesta
o la estáis perdiendo?
La estáis perdiendo.
¿Qué simboliza la fiesta?
La vida.
¿Qué simboliza el invitado grosero?
Las emociones negativas
como, por ejemplo, el dolor.
¿Qué simbolizan los demás invitados?
Pues sas emociones positivas
que no les estamos prestando atención,
¿por qué? Porque vivimos detrás
de esas emociones negativas
para poder sacarla de nuestra fiesta,
para poder sacarla de nuestra vida.
Sin darnos cuenta,
que hay otro tipo de emociones
en nuestra vida, diariamente
tenemos emociones positivas,
pero no nos damos cuenta,
las dejamos pasar.
Porque estamos prestando
completa atención
a esas emociones negativas.
Y ya que hablamos de atención,
esa atención es
otro factor muy importante
para el manejo del dolor,
del dolor crónico.
Fijáros, que como he comentado antes,
cuando más intentamos ir detrás
de esos pensamientos negativos,
de esas emociones
negativas para echarlas,
menos se van de nuestra cabeza.
Por ejemplo, si yo os digo
no pensar en un elefante azul,
en vuestra mente hay un elefante azul.
Entonces no le echemos
cuenta, dejémosla,
pensemos más en esos estímulos,
emociones positivas,
porque el otro se va a ir solo.
Fijáros lo importante que es la atención
en el manejo del dolor crónico
que una persona,
cuando tiene dolor crónico,
cuando está pasando un rato agradable
con sus amigos, con su familia,
parece que le duele menos ¿cierto?
Cuando está aburrida,
cuando está enojada,
cuando está triste,
parece que le duele más.
¿Por qué? Y el diagnóstico es el mismo.
Porque le prestamos muchísima
atención a esos estímulos negativos,
que no dejamos que se vayan
de nuestra mente.
Porque cuanto más vamos detrás de
esos pensamientos, esas emociones,
menos se van a ir.
Fijaos que para
el manejo de la atención
hay dos factores, dos formas
de manejar la atención
con respecto al dolor crónico.
Uno es el manejo de
la atención por distracción,
es decir, yo miro a un estímulo positivo
y por ende si yo le presto
atención a un estímulo positivo,
le voy a prestar menos atención
a un estímulo negativo.
Por tanto, la percepción
subjetiva del dolor es menor
Después hay otro factor
que es el manejo de la atención
por la imaginación.
Fijaos que la imaginación
es un arma terapéutica increíble.
Es un arma que tenemos
todos y cada uno de nosotros,
es una arma teraupética increíble
y no la utilizamos,
hasta hoy en día de momento.
Espero que siga así, no nos pueden
controlar la imaginación.
Llegará el día que
nos pongan un chip y demás
y sepan lo que estamos imaginando,
pero de momento, no.
La imaginación
es personal, es de cada uno,
utilicémosla de forma teraupética
para una mejor calidad de vida,
sobre todo para las personas con dolor.
Os cuento una anécdota de un colega
que estaba en Sevilla y estaba
en un hospital en la unidad de paliativos.
Entonces le dijo un médico,
hablando con el colega,
tengo un paciente que le queda
poco, está por morir;
y bueno, no sé lo que
le está pasando, pero tiene un picor.
Cuando uno se va ya,
que está a la puerta de irse,
lo que intentan médicos
y profesionales de la salud,
es que esos últimos días
sean los más agradables posibles.
Y le comentó al compañero,
no lo podemos conseguir,
porque tiene un picor
horrendo en el cuerpo,
muy fuerte y le estamos dando
todo tipo de medicamento,
pero el picor no se va.
Entonces el colega le dijo,
¿en qué habitación está?
Le dijo la habitación y
en su momento le dijo, voy a entrar.
Entra y se ve allí al paciente
tumbado en la cama,
se presenta y le dice,
"Cierra los ojos, imagínate
que estás en la playa
y todo tu cuerpo está cubierto de arena,
la arena de playa con el salitre, pica;
entonces imagínate que ese picor
que tienes en el cuerpo
está causado por esa arena de la playa,
porque tienes tu cuerpo
completamente cubierto.
Ahora, voy a agarrar un pañuelo,
y te voy a ir sacando la arena.
Conforme te voy sacando
la arena de tu cuerpo,
el picor va a ir desapareciendo.
Salió, al rato se encontró
con el médico y le dice,
"¿Qué hiciste? No le pico más".
Fue... murió, a los pocos días,
murió esa persona,
pero no le pico más.
Los últimos días de su vida,
los pasó de forma más placentera.
Fijaos el poder de la imaginación,
fijaos en lo que nos pasa
y vuelvo a repetir con el título
de esta charla, lo que nos pasa
depende de nostros mismos.
No tenemos que depender
tanto de cosas externas.
Está bien, cuando hay dolor crónico
y hay un pico de dolor crónico,
está bien tomar medicamentos.
Pero hay que aprender, por ejemplo,
imaginaos,
me levanto en la mañana,
estoy tumbado en mi sofá,
lo que le gustaría a todo mundo,
y tengo una persona
que me va a hacer los mandados.
Esa persona me va a comprar
el periódico, la carne, el pan,
y yo tan tranquilo.
El sueño de todo mundo, ¿verdad?
Claro, pero llega un momento,
que esa persona no está más,
yo salgo a la calle y
cuando salgo a la calle,
miro para un lado, miro para el otro,
y digo, ¿dónde se compra el periódico?
¿Dónde se compra la carne?
¿Y el pan?
No sé, ¿por qué?
Porque no aprendí,
porque delegué las cosas
que tenía que haber aprendido
en un agente externo.
El agente externo es la medicación
que no estamos hablando
que la medicación esté mal;
no, porque aquí de lo que se trata
es que la persona
con este tipo de dolencia,
lleva un tratamiento multidisciplinario,
pero yo con ese chico
que me hace los mandados,
yo voy a acompañarlo.
Yo voy con él a comprar el periódico,
voy con él a comprar la carne,
voy con él a comprar el pan.
Y cuando esa persona no está más,
yo sé a donde ir.
Igual pasa con el dolor crónico,
igual pasa con la medicación.
Yo me tomó la medicación
cuando hay un pico de dolor,
pero mientras me estoy tomando
la medicación del dolor,
estoy aprendiendo estrategias
como el manejo de la atención,
el manejo de las emociones
para intentar que la percepción
del dolor subjetiva sea menor.
Porque ya sabemos que el dolor
se produce 100 % en el cerebro.
Claro, eso es lo que se intenta
y lo que intentamos
que la gente aprenda,
que todas esas estrategias
están dentro de uno, de una persona.
No hay personas que sepan más
ni que sepan menos,
simplemente no conocen
esas estrategias,
y por lo tanto, no las usa.
Lo que hay que hacer es que las sepan.
Fijaos que yo hice un tratamiento
de intervención psicológica
sobre el dolor crónico,
aquí en el hospital Heras,
realicé un par de tratamientos.
En ese par de tratamientos,
lo hice en grupo,
y quise en una jornada mostrar
los resultados que salieron,
unos resultados magníficos.
En esa jornada, le pregunté
a una serie de pacientes,
si querían dar su testimonio.
La mayoría dijo que sí,
y al final de la jornada,
los pacientes dieron su testimonio;
fijaos que había
pacientes que tomaban,
no sé si conocéis la Pregabalina,
que se tomaban
15 Pregabalinas a la semana.
Llegaron a tomarse tres a la semana.
Es una reducción
bastante importante, ¿no?
Incluso hubo pacientes
que la eliminaron.
Y yo me acuerdo que,
al final de la jornada,
estaban los pacientes
terminando de comentar
su experiencia en todo el proceso
del tratamiento psicológico
sobre el dolor crónico,
una persona del público
le preguntó a una de las pacientes,
"¿Y ahora que no toma medicación,
qué toma Usted para su dolor?"
Ella le contestó,
"Tomo mejores decisiones".
Fijáros, eso es lo que se pretende,
tomar mejores decisiones
con respecto al dolor crónico,
pero no sólo en el dolor crónico,
sino en la vida.
Porque la vida depende
de nosotros mismos,
nosotros somos los
que manejamos la vida,
no agentes externos.
Eso es lo que se pretende
y sobre todo en el dolor crónico,
que se tomen mejores decisiones
con respecto a esa medicación,
que vamos acompañando
con un entrenamiento previo,
una enseñanza de estrategia
para empezar a manejar
un poco ese tipo de dolor,
porque el dolor depende
de uno mismo, sin duda.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)